Right. Right. But, uh, but
let's talk about clicks.
One of the things we talked about the
other day, his traffic assignment,
so I know you asked me this,
they're fighting for their lives.
It's a serious issue,
but I just like to point out their
lives never existed in the media space.
Please explain that because
that was one of the more,
most illuminating aspects of our
conversation on the phone. Yeah. Um, it's,
it's publicly known,
but not talked about a whole lot
that these media organizations,
mostly these digital news startups
don't actually get a lot of use.
So what they do is,
it's called a traffic assignment.
There's a company called
comscore that tracks the, the,
the viewership that unique
views these sites have.
If you're trying to attract investment
and you say we get 20 million views per
month, they're going to say, that's cool,
but this site gets 60. What do they do?
Well, there are some sites,
this is according to variety,
modern farmer.com. What?
What does that, I have, I have
no idea. I've never heard of it.
But there are many sites which you've
probably seen where it's like the top 25
celebrities who you know,
mess up their makeup. Yes.
You click the page and I'll show you a
photo. In order to see the next photo,
you got to click the next page.
That's that way they turn you one
person at 25 unique views are 25 years.
I don't want to say unique then
accompany like vice for instance,
we'll buy the assignment of your
traffic and attributed to themselves.
So when the comscore numbers come out it
will say all of those views from those
clickbait sites are actually
vice. Right. That's fucking crazy.
And so there was a controversy a
bit, again, I'm quoting variety here,
I don't want to get sued,
but variety said that their traffic
went down 17% because someone they were
buying traffic assignment from was like
going through turmoil and shake and
being checked, shaken up. And
another one of their traffic,
Simon partners switched
to, I think like, you know,
it got sold to NBC or something. So. So
what ends up happening? Well, I can say,
um, a little bit. There was
a company that, uh, was a
prominent digital news outlet.
I knew someone there who was,
um,
decently high up who told me our company
is contemplating whether or not we
should engage in traffic assignments
to inflate our numbers. And I said,
don't do it. Like, that's wrong. And
they said, but we need investment.
So I wonder if is that fraud?
Yes.
But if comscore is,
is just lumping the numbers
together and I go to you and say,
according to comscore, our network
brings in 60 million. I didn't lie.
That's all true. Yes, that's
true. So here's what happens.
These companies get massive investment.
They don't actually generate
enough clicks or enough money.
Then once the investment runs out,
those jobs never existed. Those were,
those were padded by investors.
So God, that squirrely,
everything collapses. It seems like
fraud. I mean it does to me. Yeah.
That seems like if that was, if
you were doing that with, uh,
some tech stock. Yup. Yeah. Right? Yep.
Yeah. Musically or something
like that. You know, uh,
I was told by another individual was
headed one of these digital companies that
he felt like what we were seeing was
akin to the securities, uh, problem.
The expense that a mortgage back
securities from designate it.
If that's a better analogy. That's what
he said. He said, I'm thinking about this.
You've had all of these big companies,
these big investment,
hundreds of millions of dollars,
$200 million investment into these digital
media outlets because they're seeing
these numbers. But underneath there's
nothing there. And it's crazy.
So if you're investing money, so
if you've got some, some cash,
you've worked your ass off and you've
generated a lot of money and you're like,
look,
we're going to get into the digital space.
We have a website that has 90 million
clicks and we're going to take that.
And then you find out you just
got fucking host. How has that,
not fraud because buyer beware?
Well,
because there's laws that legalized
fraud. You know, here's, here's the thing,
right? I use a lot. Is it a law? But
it, look, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's an interesting loophole. It's not
fraud. Because they didn't lie to you,
they didn't deceive you.
You had every opportunity to look at those
numbers and see where they came from,
to understand what their network
was. Okay, well that may be the case,
but the act of doing it,
the act of the fact that you can do it
and really you're getting monitored.
It's fucking crazy shady. But I'll
tell you, I'll tell you what else.
Something else too. And I, and I say
this with the utmost respect for,
for Shane Smith who, um, you know, I
worked at vice, we've gone out for drinks.
They flew me out. I love Shane. He's
a cool dude, but he's brilliant.
Absolutely brilliant. He
is, he is a master of, uh,
I don't know what you disco w we would
call it, but it's a form, uh, you know,
so I grew up with a bunch of hacker
buddies and it in a small little hacker
community and social engineering. It's
something that I've been, you know,
relatively well versed in. And Shane,
whether he knows it or not really,
really understands how people think
and how to get them to do things.
So I'll give you a fat,
fat. A fascinating example.
I left device in 2014 and after I left,
some of the people I had had brought on
through recommendation were still there.
This buddy of mine says, dude,
good news. I'm going to be running.
I'm going to be helping produce the
news program for the cable channel.
I was like, wow, congratulations.
Does that mean you're
moving to Toronto? He goes,
why would I move to Toronto and I was
like to work on the cable channel.
This is back in 2014 he goes, we talking
about we're getting a cable channel.
I'm going to work on the new show, and
I was like, dude, it was a Rogers deal.
The cable channels in Canada.
It wasn't a couple of years later.
So they got the u s based channel.
But what happened was a bunch of my
friends who worked at vice didn't know the
cable channel they got
was based in Canada,
but they believed they were going to be
working on a cable channel in the u s
that's important because you need people
to really want to work there and be
passionate.
And Shane was a master of giving you
just enough information so that you
believed in what you were doing without
realizing it's actually not that great.
And I've got, I'm not trying to be
Dick, I think Shane's fantastic.
I don't blame him for this,
but it's clever.
You get a bunch of employees who believe
they're going to be on this big new
American cable channel. Well, she never
said American. He just had cable channel.
It's your fault for assuming
it was going to be an America,
but that meant a lot to those employees.
So you're able to boost the morale,
get everybody really excited
until they find out was in Canada.
And then they were like, wait,
what? What? Eventually they did.
They did get their US channel. But
that's, you know, Shane's, he's brilliant.
He really is. He's a, he's, you ever
play civilization? The video game? No,
it's fantastic. I love this game.
I'm playing civ six right now and,
and you can get, they're called great
people. They're called great people, uh,
that if you earn enough points,
you'll get, you'll get like Galileo,
he'll appear in your civilization museum.
I firmly believe that in a hundred
years. The next, you know, sisalation 50,
you'll be able to earn a great merchant
to Shane Smith because of how, like I,
you know,
he was able to build this empire.
He did it through very clever ways of
getting investment. And I admittedly,
I really liked the stuff they used to do
back in the day. I think the guys, wow,
he,
he knows how to do it.
And the reason I bring him up is because
the big story about traffic assignment
was vice losing like 17% because
of that practice they were doing.
So he really knew how to do the
smoke and mirrors. You know what,
when you look at the other, uh,
when you look at how it pays out,
plant pans out to all the other news
outlets and then having gets laid off,
you have to, one, you don't,
you don't have to wonder why a thousand
jobs just got lost in the past week.
It was just investment money.
And once they reached their threshold,
it all came crashing down. The,
the, the modern farmer example,
like the modern farmer, what does
it, I think it's just the clicks.
Just the fact that that you can actually
buy those clicks and attribute them to
something different. And then you can tell
people in the oil company views I got,
yeah, do that and send it over
to Joe rogan.com Yo. Yeah.
And there's other really
clever things to like, um,
I don't think this one is on par,
but make you have one youtube channel
with a thousand subs, make 10 more.
Ask all your subs to subscribe.
Now you've got 10,000 subs, get it.
Same thousand people 10 times. And
you've got, you go around telling people,
I've got 10,000 subscribers when in
reality it's just a thousand people on 10
channels. So it was really clever ways
to inflate your numbers and this attracts
investment. It'll it also,
but more importantly,
it allows leverage in dealing with
ad with ad buyers and ad networks.
What are people doing when they're
boosting up their Instagram numbers? Uh,
I don't know a lot about Instagram trying
to pull it up. I can't show you. Right.
And I just went to a website by you,
two views.com for $2,800.
You can have a million views that's there.
There's, there's, there's, there's um,
there's, there's good reasons to do
it. Not if you want to be a youtuber.
If you want to be successful on youtube,
buying views ensures you will never
make it. But look at it this way.
No one do this. No one, I
am not advocating for one.
I'm about to explain film 10 videos,
a full season of a,
the Joe Rogan travel adventure
by a million views on
each to be padded out over
a month. Go to a and,
e, look at this show,
we launched million views per
episode. You want to buy it? Wow.
It's got a bunch of fans, a million people
watch you see the episodes. Fantastic.
You seen it. You see what I mean? Yes.
Well if you're full of shit, but hey,
there are people who,
who it's snake oil is people who do this.
But here's the thing, you get
access to a network with real views,
you'll get traffic, right. You know, if
you can trick your way into getting on TV,
fake it till you make it, it's dirty. It's
a, it's illegal. Right. And that's fraud.
Well actually I don't know if that, I
don't think it is fraud if while I am the,
the clicks like that, I think,
I think New York, there was,
someone sent me an article that uh,
the attorney general of ones
that may have been New York said,
misrepresenting yourself online through
fake views, clicks and likes is illegal.
I think what they were saying is that
using other people's images to create fake
accounts is like invasion
of privacy or something.
But we're getting to that point. But you
know, there's people who play that game,
I guess you, you, you can really,
you can really pull it off.
I've met a lot of people who,
there's a bunch of tricks, man.